HAWAII HISTORY, BUE
DEADLIEST FIRE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, WHICH IS 85 IN
RA
ANK YO
>>> BEHIOUSEND SFRONT A LY L BU
ICONT BEST KNOWNOR E FIRST MOUTE
EVER CREAT F ROLLING
RECORD SLEEVE BACK.EATURED EN TE
HE WAS ABOUT T
T
LAHAINA.
MUCH FOR
THE TIME TO LK T.
AND WE'RE SO SORRY F
EVERYTHING YOU'VE LOST
ON FRONT STREET IN LAHING FOR TP
RIGHT?
OR, YEAH.
IT WAS -- WE'DG FOI H IS
RIGHS.D IT, WETH OVE
MAUI.
SO, WEHIPPED OVE0 RE
KUALA, UPOU
AND MYEE
WORKINAND THE TRACK LI
BUILDE AND HANGING PAINTIGOINGO
BE READY TUESDAY FOR THE GRAND .
HT
THE GALLERY, AND PPL
COMING IN ADOH, I WA TTHISWA
TO BUY THIS.OUW WH? GOING TO  H
TOMORR.OVE TO SAY HELLO
YOU ANSHWH
COME B
OPENEY N WOW
O, NO, NO,TOMORROW.
SO, THAI OKAY.XT, THS WERE LIK0
PER
A 150-POUND
IT'S REALLY GETTINWALK. CSA
SA, BETTER COME ON
CK
LO HERED OWEREE ROAD USE OF THE.
D TH OUTT IT WAS AE THEY.
THEY CMYAWLL
ER THRE TOOTH PICKS.
, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IFG , A HOTET ONE HOHALA
NOTHING.ER
.
I IDOKAY.T A U-HAUL.
W, BO
BLOWUP B
HE FOUR DOGS .
T TWO BLOWUPS,BLANKETS, SHEETSOA
O, IT.AINTIN BOUGHT FROM YOUD I.
WEITK AN GET
MOOPLE ARE A RUBY, I CMAT  LIKEH
N, JUST BEAT
THE TIME.
ADD EY GAVE ME SIX MONTHTOE.
WIT A BOUT
SO, D CAN TAKE ME DOMYIFIN TS
EES LO
MYAS IOD
I  THERN
INFIRE
D THERE WA STANDING.ONGST ALL TD
TILL THERE
>>E BT.
T